How are we looking? Rough around the edges?
Then we're looking like our true selves.
Oh no.
Hi, my name is Grace Helbig. If you didn't know, well now you know. Your life is different now!
I went down a wormhole of Mikey or Glam & Gore
who is an amazing make up artist.
Videos were she made herself into, like, this pastel goth.
And then she made herself into, like, a 2000s version of herself.
And they were so fun to watch
and she's obviously a professional make up artist so she was very good at it
but I thought, y'know, I just turned myself into my dog...
What's the next obvious transformation?
The iconic denim dress duo that was Britney Spears and Justin Timberlake
in 2001 at the American Music Awards.
What's better than wearing a denim dress?
Making it at home on video for the internet.
Plus I went on Twitter and asked you guys for inspiration
of your favourite, like, 90s/2000s look
and so many of you recommended this
that I decided "denim-in".
Denim.
D-d-d-denim. Da-d-denim. Da-denim.
De-demin. D-de-demin.
I just bought a lot of denim.
So today I'm gonna try and create Britney Spears' 2001
American Music Awards denim iconic look.
"Icon-not" think of a better red carpet outfit than that.
Ugh, where does my t-shirt stop and the denim begin?
I'm also gonna actually try-
Ugh! They were so young and so...
... poorly influenced by the people around them.
I'm pretty sure there's a lot of you that watch this video
that weren't even born when this happened.
People were making mistakes, and or, miraculous statements forever.
So I bought a f*** tonne of denim from the craft store
and when I was buying it the very lovely woman that was helping me buy it
was, like, "Oh what do you plan on making?"
and I was like...
"A bodice... shirt thing
and I just need a lot of material
because I know I'm probably gonna screw it up so..."
And she was like "Oh, that's... nice".
I knew she knew I was lying.
A girl my age doesn't walk into Joann Fabrics
and buy this much denim fabric
without them knowing that I'm trying to make
a Britney Spears denim dress.
♫ "Now get to work bitch!" ♫
Here we are!
I have all kind of rhinestones.
I'm even gonna attempt to make this goddamn denim matching purse
so get f***ing ready.
I never made a denim dress before.
Ugh, shocking! I know.
Guess what my Marvel superhero name is?
Denim!
Like Venom? K.
Oh *rips* Here we go.
Oooh and we did it.
We goddamn did-
It's like as if they did the musical Rent at Stagecoach.
Give me a marker, please.
Also Britney Spears' Instagram -
highly recommend it if you're not already following it.
It's one of the best goddamn grams.
This is already wrong but-
There's nothing wrong about this look.
What do you think her stylist said to her
when they both tried this on?
Do you think she walked to her stylist's house or apartment
or office and the stylist was like
"I've got this best idea.
Real Housewife meets Nashville Project Runway... Project."
Cute!
I'm not gonna do a tonne of talking-
Ow! F***! F***! Ahh!
Gosh... get it to stay...
Oh this gon' be bad.
I mean I could just tie it in the back.
And I cut some of the excess off the bottom.
Ow!
♫ "Now get to work bitch!" ♫
That's a pleasant ASMR sound!
*rips*
♫ "Now get to work bitch!" ♫
What's Tim Gunn's cover of "Work Bitch"?
"Make It Work Bitch".
Okay, where we at?
Other than my pit stains because I'm sweating so much
'cause I'm nervous about doing this bad.
Oh, boy. This going to be bad.
All about the contrasting patchwork-
Really want this dress to look like Joey Fatone's hair
during the height of N*Sync.
Just kinda patchy.
La la la.
Think if I cared about being patient
I could really make this look, like, really good, but I don't.
Name a more iconic piece of fashion.
I'll wait.
It's good when it's this open in the back.
One of the genius things about this look is that-
the subtleties are bound.
One being - the matching denim clutch
that she is holding which we're gonna try and make right now.
Have I ever made a clutch? Oh hell no.
But we've got plenty of denim left over.
Taco coming in clutch.
Let's trace another taco.
Fold that over and glue that part down.
♫ "Now get to work bitch!" ♫
If Britney Spears and Justin Timberlake, like, had gotten pregnant this night
that would make Justin a denim daddy.
That's a thing, right?
I want to glue these back to back
and then turn it inside out!
♫ "Now get to work bitch!" ♫
Ow! Ow!
While this cools down, I'm gonna heat things up
with a plug from one of my favourite companies
Audible!
You guys know that I have been working with Audible forever!
Both of my books are available as audiobooks on Audible.
If you haven't heard about them, let me know how that rock is that you're living under.
They have an unmatched selection of not only audiobooks
but now shows - um - news, podcasts, etc etc etc.
They're just constantly expanding.
Plus they make it super easy for you to switch devices
if you're in between listening something.
You can go from listening on your phone in your car
to - err - your Echo when you get home.
It just makes it very seamless.
Plus they have speed control so you can listen fast or slow
or depending on how much attention you're giving to it.
And any audiobooks that you get are yours to keep,
it's not like a rental, you own it now.
Plus, this is extra fitting-
unlike what this dress will be-
because Mamrie Hart, my best friend, who actually
I went to see Britney Spears' -er- show in Vegas with
has her new book "I've Got This Round" available in audiobook form on Audible,
and you can get your first audiobook for free on:
My name.
Or you can text 'Grace' to 500-500.
And now back to-
what is shaping up to be a bad decision - here we go!
Now we turn our taco purse inside out.
Ah, that's kind of a clutch!
The whole taco purse is super rhinestoned.
I bought a tonne of rhinestones.
I'm gonna do some detail work.
♫ "Now get to work bitch!" ♫
Oh, motherf-!
Oww!
♫ "Now get to work bitch!" ♫
Found a silver chain from an old thing that I had so-
more hot glue!
Let that set!
*sighs*
This is so stressful and I already feel like this is not worth it at all whatsoever but-
aye we're doing it - yay!
So Britney does have major accessories other than
her dazzling smile and personality
and loose grip on her own reality.
Obviously the, um, completely rhinestone chocker
and matching bracelet, and the belt that I think
my step-mom bought at a Chico's once.
At the craft store I found this headband
that I thought could be a choker if I just put, like,
more of these rhinestones on it.
As we all know now is a very easy, fun activity to do.
What is the point of it?
*goose barks*
That must mean Brooks is here.
Hi, Brooks!
I'm making a video.
Did you guess what I'm doing? But- don't look at this!
Based on what you see on this table right here,
what do you think I'm doing?
Whose look?
*laughs*
Iconic 2001 Britney-Justin denim dream.
Yeah.
So like you're- eyes on the prize.
Okay! All my accessories have been beautifully, beautifully handmade-
beautiful accessories are done-ish for now.
Now it's time to get the make up look as best we can.
Though her make up for this look isn't that ridiculous.
Very thin eyebrows. Lot of bronzer.
Let's do it!
Make her eyebrows much more muted, much more like
they came to the party but they don't really want to be there.
It's me at every party.
Oh, she's got blue eyeshadow too! Oh man.
We're gonna really go over these eyebrows.
Just blend this in.
This- but this is that good bronzer that doesn't make orange-
♫ "Now get to work bitch!" ♫
Mm. Nailing it.
Oh, that's a different colour.
I usually fill my eyebrows in with, like, a darker brown
but her eyebrows look almost orange?
Use some of these colours and see what I can get out of it.
♫ "Now get to work bitch!" ♫
Sort of.
Okay, cute!
There we go!
Next is- we got some blue eyeshadow to do
and some white highlighting around the eyes.
♫ "Now get to work bitch!" ♫
Yeah, that seems right. That seems good.
Now we need blue!
Interstellar palette? That sort of has silvery blue?
Here's a dirty brush. Why not!
♫ "Now get to work bitch!" ♫
Now we need some black eyeliner.
Yeah that seems close.
I don't think she's wearing fake eyelashes but I can't tell.
So I'm just gonna put some of this.
This is now just becoming what I looked like when I went to prom.
Ooh, lips!
Did we do it? Kinda.
I think our make up look is kind of all there,
so let's put the whole goddamn thing together,
and see what happens. Here we go!
*dramatic music plays*
Really great. Really, really great.
I mean, it's basically identical.
And I'm really proud of myself for spending, y'know,
2+ hours on this.
Okay guys, if you like this video give it a thumbs up!
Let me know in the comments down below who you think
I should make a "recre-Gracation" of in the future,
'cause that's what we used to kind of call these videos
"recre-Gracations" and clearly, they're worth every moment of it so-
Leave a comment down below,
and hit that bell notification so you know when I upload videos
because it- is- just so inconsistent!
Other than that, I don't know.
Ugh! We made a mess.
*bang*
That's Britney Spears' energy.
Kidding! I love her! She great.